we got a bug you about a another one
who's skyrocketing Zoey Catwoman are you
freaking kidding me how much is she
gonna kill that wrong go proud it's
perfect casting it's perfect kill it you
know I was with Robert Pattinson earlier
today cuz he's the back over and he said
I love her I've known her for 10 years
just gonna be so amazing how do you feel
about Robert being cast I'm really
really stoked yeah he's a good man's
great actor him I'm excited about the
whole thing can we ever get the three of
you in a movie
I'm happy awesome but I don't think it's
going that way why not let's just let
them do their thing my thing all right
we are what we fight as one
this show it's so emotional it's so
intense but of course I'm sure the first
question everyone asks you is what is it
like to play these blind characters I
think you had a consultant on set how
did you go about learning to be in that
mindset all the time
less of a mindset and more of a
practical thing is like learning how to
navigate the physical world without
sight is the way we define it but you
can hear there's echo echo location you
can tell when you pass through space
just by the air when people are close to
you I mean it was it was being led to an
awareness of all the possibilities of
how you can see without actually senses
or handicap because of the first sight
so many ways it's just like
strengthening all the senses that we've
kind of just suppressed so by doing the
training and doing it with partners and
doing with groups and doing those
fighting and and all those different
types of training it's it's really cool
because we had a lot of time in a month
of different types of training to do it
and then always having movement and
blind coach on set before we go to the
scenes and what was the most important
practice that helped you feel like it
was being made authentic the battle
scenes are intense I mean watching those
try catching an axe when you can't look
at it it's not fun like you get hit
there's this yeah there's you got hit oh
yeah really I mean I can't talk you
can't make eye contact if the cameras on
you you're not supposed to see if you
don't know what's coming so like you're
walking it someone couldn't do a move
you got to be keep your head down you
ever like keep contact and all these
different grappling hooks so we designed
a whole different fight fighting style
okay any new scars for you yes yes lots
of aperture in this did cross my mind
Jason this is a big question who would
win in a battle I think it's not fairies
oh well drug is just like
yeah it's not fair you're standing
strong for Baba because you know why you
got probably will hurt him he died you
know what I love about Baba though is he
has this emotional fatherhood side of
him that scene where he is talking about
how much he would love the twins a boy
and a girl in your character has just
delivered them that's such an emotional
way to start a show and I was kind of
watching it wondering how personal that
was for you because you have a boy and a
girl and you're talking about loving
these children and that's you you're
this tough guy but you're such a family
man - yeah I think I can't stand using
my kids and anything for my mental
preparation because it I would it would
be so horrible for me and you know I
mean it can't be that close it wouldn't
fit so but we've done so much work and I
love Archie and Nesta and just you know
we were quickly second episode the
rarity of age and so I've made a lot of
great things where you know you know
Archie's six six or something like that
but I'm always down lower and I'm always
got my hand out in front of them even
though I can't he can see I'm still
always protecting my son which is just
little things that the father would do
for his son it's just how we get around
and how noise but we just make them all
very real and I love them so just just
put your mindset there and do your job
and then when you lose them I'm not all
thinking about my kids because it just
wouldn't be right but as we go on
because it is essentially a story about
family the stakes get higher and higher
higher between the two of you who would
really survive in a dystopian world I
thought she's got the smart know we look
we are learning together we try out
together she's and we know how to share
power that's the thing you can't you
know there's no I'm not gonna name names
but oh no
um I gotta ask you uh
Alfre you're getting such Oscar buzz for
clemency
look at him cheer you stop Momoa you
know I don't believe in buzz but it's
crazy that you don't ever you have not
ever actually gotten one how would it
feel for you to get that recognition you
know most actors have never been
nominated for an Oscar I want that for
you know certain films that we remember
yes that are our favorite films through
the decades have not been nominated so
it is the norm for people not to be
nominated but I appreciate ya I
appreciate you just season-opener like
you know the good thing about buzz it
gets eyes on the actual film yes or the
actual series that you want people to
see
[Music]
[Applause]